transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely imagine
that Michael Knowles or whoever had said
we need to eradicate Judaism
oh my God are you calling for for
genocide no no no no I didn't say
anything about eradicating Jews I meant
eradicate Judaism completely
do you think we would all accept that
and go oh okay
it's fine he's not saying anything about
Jews he's just saying eradicate Judaism
get rid of it completely oh yeah the
Anti-Defamation League would be fine
with that defense he is saying out loud
in more explicit terms what a ton of
these right Wingers are thinking and
it's dangerous and it's disgusting and
it needs to be condemned and he can't be
allowed to walk it back by going no no I
didn't say anything about trans people I
meant just get rid of the ism what do
you what exactly do you mean by that